[Musique]
mais tu es fou rythmes de l'afrique
la coupe d'afrique des nations du 9
janvier au 6 février sur france 24
[Musique]
chaque jour nous faisons des gestes qui
nous protège et protège les autres
[Musique]
contre le coc u19 la grippe et les virus
de l'hiver gardons le réflexe des gestes
barrières
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24 la
commission européenne s'apprête à
classer le nucléaire comme énergie verte
le gaz et le nucléaire se voir reconnu
comme des énergies durables mais sous
certaines conditions
ce débat est bien sûr très technique
mais il est essentiel et il divise les
européens à bruxelles ce texte est
connue sous le nom de taxonomie verte
européenne les énergies considérée comme
durable bénéficie de meilleures
conditions de financement
l'objectif pour l'union européenne c'est
de parvenir à la neutralité carbone en
2050 alors c'est bien sûr une victoire
pour la france puisque le nucléaire
fournit 70 % de son électricité
l'allemagne au contraire a choisi de
sortir du nucléaire et avec l'autriche
et le luxembourg et la livrer une
bataille contre l'inclusion du nucléaire
parmi les énergies durables berlin a en
revanche batailler pour que le gaz soit
bien inclus au moment où le pays
s'apprête à accroître ses achats de gaz
russe alors le nucléaire est il vraiment
une énergie verte pourquoi la france
pour la france c'est essentiel et cette
question peut-elle faire exploser la
coalition allemande kehl finalement
quelles conséquences sur les choix
énergétiques européens on en parle donc
dans le débat avec comme invité j'ai à
mes côtés marina bertieaux notre
spécialiste environnement journaliste à
france 24 bonsoir marina vous présentait
donc je crois que ces deux fois par mois
c'est ça élémentaire notre émission
spécialiste environnement et dont ses
émissions de reportages merci d'être
avec nous marina avec nous également
mode brégeon bonsoir vous êtes
porte-parole la république en marche
ingénieurs également dans le nucléaire
bienvenue dans le débat
bonsoir avec nous également michèle
rivasi eurodéputée europe ecologie les
verts bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
également
bonsoir alors avant de démarrer cette
discussion puisqu'on sait donc la
commission européenne s'apprête à
classer le nucléaire comme énergie verte
vous allez regardez ce reportage de nos
confrères et consoeurs de france
télévisions confrères de france
télévisions julien gasparotto françois
ducobu et sylvain guillaume
les centrales nucléaires et les
centrales à gaz
labellisé investissements verts est donc
bénéfique au climat
c'est la décision très controversée que
s'apprête à prendre la commission
européenne dans ce rapport à le propose
de casser le gaz et le nucléaire comme
des énergies nécessaires à la transition
climatique une position défendue par la
france on a besoin de toutes les
énergies décarbonées pour lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique on a d'abord
besoin des énergies renouvelables mais
aussi du nucléaire
concrètement cela veut dire que les
investisseurs privés seront incités à
placer leur argent dans le gaz ou le
nucléaire une aubaine pour la france qui
souhaite renouveler son parc et vendre
des centrales à l'étranger
mais les pays anti nucléaire comme
l'allemagne l'autriche ou le luxembourg
font déjà entendre leur opposition la
proposition de la commission est une
provocation pour
obtenir le label la commission
européenne exige toutefois des garanties
une gestion très stricte des déchets
nucléaires ou un faible taux d'émission
pour le gaz
insuffisant au regard des écologistes on
ne peut pas dire que le nucléaire
aujourd'hui sérieusement est une énergie
durable qu'elles émettent pas beaucoup
de co2 c'est une chose mais n'allons pas
investir de l'argent pour de nouvelles
folies nucléaire comme des ep en france
orienteront les financements européens
vers les énergies renouvelables plutôt
que vers le nucléaire et le gaz
michèle rivasi alors que pensez vous de
cette inclusion de certaines à certaines
conditions donc on a vu du nucléaire
comme énergie renouvelable nucléaire
est-il vert
bah écoute et ça a été un rapport de
force incroyable cette taxonomie
c'était on avait établi des critères et
pour ça il y avait un groupe d'experts
qui ont relaté au moins deux critères
majeurs le premier c il faut que ces
énergies diminue les gaz à effet de
serre et ça c'est vrai que le nucléaire
rentrer dans cette case et le deuxième
gros critères c'était que ça ne nuisent
pas à l'environnement
c'est à dire à une pollution à la fois
de l'eau à la fois de l'air et puis
qu'on soit capable de gérer les déchets
or vous voyez que dans la 2 le deuxième
gros critères le nucléaire ne rentre pas
dans ce critère de des investissements
durables et au niveau du gaz et bien
c'est vrai que le premier critère là au
niveau du gaz ça ne rentre pas et c'est
moins si vous voulez ça n'implique - les
critères sur la biodiversité et sur la
pollution et là il ya eu un rapport de
force terrible la france a poussé à ce
qu' il ya un autre d'experts qu'il
intervienne et notamment c'est le jrc
qui est très proche de rats tom nom des
gens assez lié au niveau du nucléaire et
là c'est la france qui a énormément uvre
et avec un deal qu'ils ont effectués
avec les allemands en disant eh bien
nous on lâchera sur le gaz si le gaz
rentrer dans la taxonomie verte et les
allemands eh bien on dit ben nous on
lâchera sur le nucléaire alors en europe
à l'heure actuelle il ya cinq pays qui
sont contre cette taxonomie vous avez
cité l'allemagne le luxembourg il ya la
belgique et le portugal et l'espagne et
puis macron lui-même est allé se rendre
dans des pays comme la pologne comme la
hongrie comme la slovaquie et il a
trouvé une dizaine de pays pour faire en
sorte à ce que le nucléaire vous voyez
soit dans cette classification donc
c'est un combat n'est pas fini le combat
n'est pas fini le fonds ne combat n'est
pas fini parce que là ils ont sorti
cette taxonomie le 31 décembre vraiment
en toute opacité
ils ont envoyé ça aux états membres et
donc ils ont 15 jours là pour faire des
modifications par rapport à ce texte et
donc vous vous souhaiter qu'il y ait des
modifications dans ce texte
les parlementaires 20 en tout cas au
parlement européen des biens sur nous on
peut absolument pas que les
investissements en durable oui on pense
à l'avenir on pense pas seulement à
l'instant présent le nucléaire ne peut
pas rentrer dans ces critères de
taxonomie d'abord d'abord à cause de la
question du déchet d'abord à cause de la
question des déchets
mais il ya vraiment la question des
déchets parce que le nucléaire voyez
c'est quand même 23 mille tonnes par an
de production de déchets on a à peu près
1200 tonnes de combustibles usés qui
sont stockés près des centrales pour
ensuite aller au niveau de lag donc c
est à l'heure actuelle moi je me suis
rendu à à bure et tous les sites qui
veulent stocker des déchets radioactifs
que ce soit le site le whip aux états
unis que ça soit yucca mountain que ça
soit le site en suède ils ont tous eu
des pépins et ils se sont arrêtés on n'a
pas de solution en infos isme en grande
profondeur donc c'est vraiment pas une
solution et une solution notre région
pour vous alors évidemment on sait qu
emmanuel macron lui qui fait du
nucléaire sur le pilier de sa politique
énergétique
donc tout ça a été l'histoire d'un deal
comme vient de le dire justement michèle
rivasi on donne le gaz
énergies vertes pour les allemands ont
fait passer le nucléaire énergie verte
pour les français d'une sauce de
d'accord entre les deux c'est ça ce qui
s'est passé est ce qu effectivement la
question des déchets qui reste
extrêmement sensible et déchets
nucléaires est-ce que malgré cette
question des déchets le nucléaire peut
être une énergie verte
alors bonjour il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
de questions dans la question déjà vous
l'avez rappelé la taxonomie ça a pour
objectif de me de mieux orienter les
flux des capitaux vers des énergies qui
sont d'énergie des énergies du père qui
permettent la transition énergétique et
le nucléaire aujourd'hui parce que cette
énergie parce que ce mode de production
l'aimé pas de co2 fait partie au même
titre que des énergies renouvelables
d'un mode de production qui permet de
tendre vers ce sera ni té là pour vous
donner quelques chiffres en 1970 il y
avait les deux tiers de l'électricité
produite en france qui menait des
énergies fossiles
aujourd'hui on est autour de 7% et donc
c'est une vraie victoire c'est pour ça
que le président de la république a
raison de rappeler que le nucléaire est
une chance pour la france mais pour
autant les déchets autant je termine à
l'échelle mondiale est encore plus de
85% l'énergie primaire les énergies
fossiles et donc notre lutte c'est
vraiment les émissions de co2 la techno
de nous elle va permettre au nucléaire
d'attirer davantage les investisseurs
d'avoir donc un coût du capital afin
d'avoir des meilleurs taux donc un coût
du capital qui est plus bas et au final
le résultat c'est que dans le mix
énergétique européen permettent le
développement du nucléaire c'est à voir
d'une part une électricité qui est plus
verte et en plus une électricité avec un
plus faible travers vous a entendu plus
verte mais suffisamment verte malgré les
déchets c'est toujours la question votre
région sur les déchets il est faux de
dire qu'on ne sait pas quoi faire des
déchets dans le nucléaire ça c'est une
idée reçue qui est largement véhiculée
par les écologistes qui à mon sens
d'ailleurs non plus écologiste que le
nom aujourd'hui parce qu'une grande
partie de ces déchets et retraités ont
les réutilise une autre partie est
stockée de façon pérenne on sait le
faire sur des chères à petit et qui sont
pas radioactifs longtemps pour la faire
on sait aussi qu'on se parle on est
moins dans un sac le stockage des décès
des déchets c'est quand même à casquette
et est effectivement une part des
déchets aujourd'hui dont on a une
solution qui est effectivement le projet
six jours le projet d'enfouissement à
bure on a commencé à travailler sur ce
projet là en 1991 et il a été à
plusieurs reprises valider techniquement
par l'ensemble des organisations qui ont
la légitimité de pencher dessus il a été
validé de pratiquement à l'assemblée
nationale est donc aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est de notre devoir d'avancer vers
cette solution là ne serait ce que pour
ne pas laisser la charge de l'art de
l'être dit on aux générations futures
les choses je suis choquée sur cette
histoire de toc de taxonomie d'entendre
europe ecologie les verts et la transe
insoumise notamment s'insurger contre
l'inclusion du nucléaire et ne dira pas
un mot sur l'inclusion du gaz oui le gaz
fossile celui qu'on importe de la russie
de la dîmière poutine ça c'est un vrai
problème pour le climat son inclusion
dans la taxonomie ça ça doit être
questionné en revanche le nucléaire a
encore une fois ne l'aimé pas mais là
dessus il ya vraiment deux poids deux
mesures et donc on est dans une logique
électoraliste et politique pour moins de
la part de l'ulb sur cette question là
et qui peut-être rapporte des voix mais
qui à aucun moment ne fera gagner le
climat en tout cas on voit bien que
c'est aussi un c'est une question
technique marina mais c'est aussi
vraiment une question politique alors
justement marina qu'elles sont d'abord
les conditions dont parle la commission
pour justement être considéré comme vert
pour le nucléaire et pour le gaz parce
que les conditions sont strictes alors
déjà ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que ces deux énergies se sont un peu
glissé au dernier moment dans les
projets verts européens et donc
effectivement à certaines conditions
pour que les installations nucléaires et
gazière soit placée comme énergie de
transition pour avoir ce label vert et
bien il faut qu'elles répondent à
certains critères d'abord pour le
nucléaire il ya une limitation de temps
le permis de construire des nouvelles
centrales doit avoir été donné avant
2045 c'est pour les nouvelles et les
travaux de prolongement des centrales
déjà existantes avoir été autorisé avant
2040 et puis assorties de garanties
entre guillemets avec beaucoup de
guillemets de plans de gestion des
déchets radioactifs on en parlait
justement voisin de garantie de gestion
des déchets marina dont parle la
commission et bien il faut que
l'entreprise en l'occurrence edf en
france garantit qu'elle a un plan pour
gérer ses déchets alors moi
personnellement je suis allé pour
l'émission alimentaire voir comment ça
se passe ce site d'enfouissement des
déchets à bure et c'est exactement ce
qu'on vient d'entendre c'est à dire que
on n'a pas une vraie solution réalité
ces déchets ils sont mis sous le tapis
c'est ça qui se passe en france à
l'heure actuelle bur c'est ça c'est un
grand tunnel dans lequel on va mettre
des déchets on va refermer et on va être
bien embêté pour les générations futures
pour savoir comment on va alors indiqué
qu'il faut surtout pas creuser parce que
c'est extrêmement dangereux alors ça
c'était pour le nucléaire je réponds à
votre question sur le gard le gaz
effectivement alors là la condition pour
le gaz c'est que ces centrales émettent
peu de co2 moins de 100 grammes de co2
par kilowattheure en réalité c'est un
seuil très bas mais il va y avoir des
exceptions ya parce qu'il ya une période
de transition évidemment jusqu'en 2030
qu'elles émettent moins de
270 grammes de co2 par kilowattheure et
ces critères là ils seront revus tous
les sens très centriste pour le gaz
extrêmement sec alors là je veux dire
des nouvelles centrales ça veut dire on
ferme les vieilles centrales à gaz alors
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que le gaz naturel on l'appelle le
gaz naturel mais en réalité c'est un gaz
fossile c'est comme ça que qu'il faut
l'appeler il aimait oui moins de co2 que
le pétrole et le charbon mais il en est
mais tout de même beaucoup donc le gaz
énergies vertes très clairement non ça
n'est pas plus renouvelable non plus que
le pétrole d'ailleurs très important
l'avis du giec et l'avis de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui nous
disent que pour atteindre les objectifs
de l'accord de paris il faut toujours
revenir à ses objectifs de l'accord de
paris et bien il ne faut plus ouvrir de
gisements de gaz pas pour rien qu'ils ne
disent pas pour rien donc ça veut dire
quoi michèle rivasi on est quand même
dans un moment de transition qui fait
que effectivement pour être un peu plus
tolérant avec le nucléaire et le gaz
pendant une période donnée je sais que
les écologistes parlent de sortir du
nucléaire en france en 2020 sessad en
2003 pardon 2040 dont 20 en 2040 ouais
oui parce que on a perdu dix ans vu que
en a pas on n'a pas suffisamment
développer les énergies renouvelables
mais vous voyez que là où c'est aberrant
cette taxonomie en incluant à la fois le
gaz et le nucléaire c'est que ça va
demander des investissements pour au
moins 40 ans jusqu'à certains 60 ans
donc vous voyez qu'on ne va pas diminuer
de façon draconienne à la fois les gaz à
effet de serre et les risques
d'accidents parce que autant le gaz
c'est une transition qu'on peut
comprendre pour fermer les centrales à
charbon voyez qui met encore plus et on
peut se dire qu'avec une meilleure
technologie il y aura moins d'émissions
mais on n'a pas tout ce problème des
déchets on n'a pas tous ce problème de
risques d'accident l'histoire du
nucléaire date d'autres problèmes à ce
que disait marina c'est à dire qu'ils
sont quand même très polluant que
manifestement il effectivement beaucoup
de technologies pour respecter les
critères de la commission et qu'en plus
il ya une dépendance dépendance
énergétique à l'égard de la russie en
l'occurrence à la fois il ya des
investissements par rapport à des
pipelines et puis ensuite il ya une
dépendance par rapport on a cité la
russie nous on pourrait citer le
moyen-orient ferrat donc nous on parle
de souveraineté et qui peut mieux
répondre sur la souveraineté sur le fait
que c'est une énergie plutôt de paix
quand on parle des énergies
renouvelables quand voilà justement
pardonnez-moi michèle rivasi pour
avancer les énergies renouvelables
peuvent-elles être la seule réponse
aujourd'hui aux besoins d'électricité en
europe et en france ça reste le même une
question importante
et bien écoutez dans tous les scénarios
vous avez que ça soit le scénario était
le scénario négawatt le scénario de
l'ademe il est possible d'être à 100%
d'énergies renouvelables en 2040 en 2050
c'est ça l'objectif qu'il faut avoir
mais dans la façon
donnez moi ça passe aussi par un mix
avec le nucléaire pas en arriver là à un
scénario il ya un scénario qui est dans
les six cantons qui ont été proposées
qui propose 100 % d'énergies
renouvelables après ça au moyen de ces
après c'est un problème de coût mais il
est tout à fait possible que ce soit au
niveau de scénario de l'ademe ou de
négawatt de sortir du nucléaire et
d'aller sur les énergies renouvelables
et là on est indépendant on est vraiment
indépendant on n'a pas ce problème des
déchets et on n'a pas ce problème de co2
et vous pensez qu'on peut le faire en
vacances
avait bien sûr alors que si on joue sur
l'investissement durable en incluant le
gaz et le nucléaire mais vous en avez
jusque là au delà de 2050 donc on sera
pas à la neutralité carbone en 2050 mois
de pression ça demande des
investissements très importants et le
nucléaire quand voit flamand vie donc on
voit le le pr2 de finlande il ya 17 ans
19 ans de retard voyez comme construit
un réacteur donc c'est beaucoup trop
long et une fois que vous avez le
réacteur et bien vous allez le conserver
minimum entre 40 et 60 ans donc on
pourra pas répondre au co2 et si vous
voulez au gaz à effet de serre donc il
faut absolument
conjuguer la sobriété c'est à dire il
faut une diminution de la consommation
énergétique
il faut vraiment isoler les bâtiments
pour que voyez moins d'émissions il faut
jouer sur les transports parce que le
co2 c'est pas que l'électricité le co2
c'est aussi les transports c'est aussi
l'agriculture oui il faut avoir une
vision globale des choses mollo région
vraiment répond réchauffement climatique
dans la région vous vous répond
justement sur cette séance questions
est-ce qu effectivement en vingt ans on
pourrait sortir du nucléaire en france
et est finalement tout misé sur le
renouvelable
alors madame l'eurodéputé a cité les
rapports de l'ademe les rapports de
vertueux les rapports du négawatt en
disant que finalement chacun disait
qu'il était tout à fait possible de
sortir du nucléaire et de faire du 100%
énergies renouvelables c'est faux et je
vous invite madame à relire les ragots m
l'ademe notamment dresse un certain
nombre de contraintes d'incertitudes
notamment le fait qu on n'assure pas que
la production et la consommation sont
égales à tout moment ce qui est un des
piliers d'un mix énergétique qui
fonctionne rte dans l'immense majorité
de ces scénarios couple le développement
des énergies renouvelables à celui du
nucléaire est certes négawatt propose
une solution 100% énergies renouvelables
mais dans ce cas là il faut expliquer
aux gens ce qu'il ya derrière en termes
de réduction des consommations de
sobriété ce que c'est un vin impliqué
sur le quotidien de chacun ce que
négawatt appelle l'art cohabitation le
fait de partager électroménager le fait
de réduire sur l'ensemble des routes de
france les limitations de vitesse et ça
vous le dit pas où en fait c'est un
modèle de régression quand vous êtes en
train de proposer à la france ensuite
pour deux mois juste une question pour
avancer quand on connaît le maquereau
parle de construire six nouveaux opèrent
les op r 2 1 des 2 paires simplifiée et
qui vont être financés à peu près j'ai
vu ses 42 milliards à peu près devrait
pour moitié de financer par l'état plus
les petits les petites centrales qui
sont en fait voués à l'exportation est
ce que ça veut pas dire tout de même que
la réforme des re choisit d'abord et
avant tout le nucléaire
le nucléaire est une chance pour la
france et c'est évidemment notre atout
majeur pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
ça protège le climat ça protège notre
indépendance nerfs et ce qu'on ne fait
pas au détriment des autres pardonnez
moi la mode brégeon c'est ça s'est passé
et
le gaz c'est une transition qu'on peut
comprendre qu est ce que vous vous
rendez compte de la part de la faim dans
la bouche d'une femme qui se dit
écologiste ce que ça signifie que de
dire ça en fait en réalité ça illustre
ce qu'on observe à l'échelle européenne
c'est aujourd'hui sortir du nucléaire
c'est choisir le gaz la belgique sort
nucléaire elle compte des centrales à
gaz aucune sortie du gaz de prévu
l'allemagne aucune sortie du gaz de
prévu et pas de sortie du pardon avant
2030 la réalité sur le climat la lame
c'est celle ci c'est uniquement celle ci
est donc la france a cette chance de
maîtriser l'énergie nucléaire et
effectivement la question du financement
est une question importante
c'est pour ça que bruno le maire c'est
pour ça que manuel mcqueen se sont
mobilisés pour que le nucléaire soit
inclus dans la taxonomie européenne pour
qu'encore une fois on puisse avoir doit
faciliter ces financements alors
justement on va en parler avec avec
marina lorsque vous dites que les
allemands ne sortent pas par exemple du
gaz ils ont fait un choix effectivement
très radicale les allemands puisqu'en
gala merkel avaient décidé de sortir du
nucléaire il ya déjà un certain nombre
d'années que la coalition donc et une
coalition un peu particulière puisque on
a à la fois les sociaux démocrates les
verts mais aussi les libéraux marina et
des objectifs ambitieux puisque ils
veulent sortir du charbon en 2030 ils
ont arrêté trois réacteurs nucléaires 31
décembre dernier donc clairement ils ont
fait un choix très différent de celui de
la france marina ce qu'ils peuvent tenir
ses objectifs ou est ce que la coalition
allemande va finir par exploser sur ce
sujet alors très clairement il faut se
pencher un peu sur les chiffres quand on
parle de l'allemagne c'est là que c'est
intéressant en allemagne pour l'instant
on a 11 à 12% de l'électricité qui vient
du nucléaire donc c'est très peu
effectivement l'allemagne sort du
nucléaire ça a été annoncé ça a été fait
et voilà ce qui est intéressant oui les
renouvelables il occupe une place très
importante on a les chiffres du dernier
trimestre 2001 21 donc c'est très récent
42% de renouvelables en allemagne même
si on a une petite baisse de 5% par
rapport à l'année d'avant mais charbon
c'est encore 27% en 2021 et donc les
renouvelables souvent les prend comme un
groupe 1 on les met tous dans le même
sac et du coup on additionne les
pourcentages voilà mais si on les prend
séparément et bien ce qu'on a c'est que
le charbon c'est encore la première
source d'énergie je vous le disais 27%
suivi de l'éolien à 22% donc très
clairement en allemagne on a un marché
qui est dominé par charbon et pas
n'importe lequel on est allés nous
l'équipe d'élémentaire faire un
reportage le charbon allemand c'est de
la limite donc on ne creuse pas en
profondeur on creuse en surface et donc
l'allemagne c'était l'objet de notre
reportage qui était pour tout vous dire
très émouvant on déplace des villages on
déplace des dizaines de milliers de
personnes pour continuer à étendre des
mines de charbon pour le mix énergétique
allemand donc oui effectivement les
allemands augmentent les renouvelables
mais assorti du charbon ça va pas être
fait c'est 2030 2000 réaliste ou pas
justement ça me semble très compliqué
surtout avec les plans alors après c'est
très récent cette coalition elle vient
elle vient et volontaire à reus qu'elle
va se donner des moyens dit à elle en
tout cas elle est sans doute qu'une
nouvelle effectivement c'était la
condition pour l'entrée des verts dans
ce gouvernement c'est cette sortie du
charbon d'ici 2030 encore faut-il
rappeler que 2030 c'est dans huit ans
donc sortir du charbon alors que je vous
le rappelle c'est 30 % quasiment 30 % du
mix énergétique allemand ils ont
vraiment du pain sur la planche on va
essayer de voir ce qui se passe mais ça
va ça va être difficile michèle rivasi
alors justement est-ce que c'est tout
problème on sort du nucléaire et en même
temps on est obligé d'utiliser de
l'énergie fossile en attendant donc le
charbon ou le gaz pour de toute façon
pas lié au manque
ils ont quand même des objectifs pour
encore développer les énergies
renouvelables
voyez qu'ils sont chez plus je crois que
c'est 2040 c'est 80 % d'énergies
renouvelables donc ils veulent fermer
leurs mines de charbon peut-être que
justement pour changer ses mines de
charbon qui sont très polluantes ils
vont peut-être utiliser le gaz dans le
cadre d'une énergie de transition mais
développer de façon très importante les
énergies renouvelables nous en france
voyez on adjoint et est monomaniaque
on a mis tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier on a développé le nucléaire de
façon incroyable vous avez vu qu areva
est en faillite et des f1 déficits et
non on a construit un ep air qui ne
marche toujours pas on en a vendu la
finlande qui ne marche toujours pas et
même les deux de chine où on a transmis
la technologie ils sont à l'arrêt depuis
le mois de juillet parce qu'ils ont là
en attendant les prêts nacre et les prix
d'électricité sont encore assez bas en
france 1 pendant oui mais c'est réguler
en france si vous voulez et on a des
réacteurs qui sont en quelque sorte
amorti maintenant le problème combat et
je vous assure et les français le
comprennent moi j'habite dans un
département le plus nucléarisé au monde
on a des centrales vieillissantes
voyez on va renouveler
la centrale de tricastin cas plus de 40
ans il ya eu encore un pépin au mois de
juillet voyez moi ce que je veux dire au
niveau du nucléaire d'abord c'est cher
le nucléaire parce que y'a tout le
carénage voyait il faut remettre aux
normes les vieux réacteurs il ya tout le
problème de la gestion des déchets comme
ça a été dit par la journaliste c'est
pas le fait de les enfouir qui fait
qu'on sait gérer les déchets radioactifs
voyez on les met sous terre point barre
avec tous les risques d'explosion
notamment par rapport à des bulles
d'hydrogène et en même temps eh bien on
déboule en poussette cette énergie qui
risque de nous exploser à la figure oui
moi je suis allé à fukushima je suis
allé à tchernobyl même à l'heure
actuelle à tchernobyl les gamins sont
malades oui alors malgré malgré tout
cela pardonnez moi et michèle rivasi
mais mal et où malgré tout ça c'est vrai
qu'il est les français en majorité
veulent garder le nucléaire en tout cas
c'est tout ce que les sondages montrent
j'aimerais voit maintenant on sait que
cette question j'aimerais bien cette
question en tout cas il y en aurait
d'ailleurs de la campagne elle est au
coeur de la campagne politique
présidentielle des présidentielles en
france je voudrais justement qu'on
écoute jean luc mélenchon le leader des
insoumis qui lui plaidait pour une
sortie du nucléaire comme vous avant
2030 puis il a repoussé cette volonté de
sortir du nucléaire à 2045 qui
proposerait maintenant un référendum sur
le nucléaire il a fait une déclaration
sur l'éolien on écoute
un réacteur nucléaire égale 45 éoliennes
offshore offshore je dis bien offshore
c'est-à-dire en mer et nous sommes
capables d'installer des éoliennes à 25
km des côtes ce sont des éoliennes qui
ont un débit de 240 m si on considère la
longueur des saletés premier projet a
été lancé il ya dix ans le l'éolien
offshore et on attend toujours sa mise
en service
vous avez raison de souligner qu'il y a
eu une criminelle lenteur et de la part
de l'état des changements d'opinion
continuelle qui rendait impossible le
travail sérieux notre région je vous
fais intervenir juste après marina c'est
possible ça ou pas ou est ce que
vraiment là jean luc mélenchon parle
d'éoliennes surpuissante en surcapacité
alors façon c'est plutôt 2 150 éoliennes
laparé accord nucléaire alors si on part
du principe en faire des matches très
rapidement un réacteur nucléaire c'est à
peu près 900 mégawatts une éolienne
offshore là jean luc mélenchon il part
du principe que c'est 20 mégawatts donc
effectivement ça en ferait 45 la réalité
quand on regarde les chiffres des
éoliennes offshore un peu partout c'est
entre 8 et 12 mégawatts en moyenne donc
ça veut dire que si on calcule assez
rapidement c'est plutôt
90,0 lienne la réalité c'est que en
france on est à peu près le seul pays
quand même bon cesse sa produirait pas
autant que les centrales nucléaires
évidemment mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas en mettre des éoliennes
offshore on est quasiment le seul pays à
pas en avoir je vais vous donner 3 4
chiffres il y en a six ans au danemark
il y en a mille cinq cent en allemagne
il y en a deux milles au large de la
grande-bretagne alors certes on n'a pas
exactement les mêmes cotes la mer du
nord allaient très peu profond disons
des conditions absolument parfaite et
nous ça fait dix ans c'est ce que disait
la journaliste sur france inter ça fait
dix ans que les autorisations elles ont
été donné et c'est pas au point mort
mais ça vient tout juste de commencer au
point mort lors qu'on parle d'un très
grand parc éolien marin qui devrait
jouer dans la mer au large du croisic
voilà donc nous nous on est allé faire
le reportage élémentaire est en réalité
ce qui se passe c'est que il ya des
recours administratifs ya des gens qui
sont contraints en france très
clairement il ya les pêcheurs parce que
ça va modifier leurs zones de pêche il y
a
les militants de l'environnement qui
pense je suis que ça va tout simplement
faire du mal à la biodiversité à la vie
marine et donc il ya une lenteur
incroyable
figurez-vous qu'en france il n'ya pas
d'éoliennes offshore qui soit
opérationnel à l'heure où je vous parle
alors que je vous parlais de ces
chiffres européens y en a une seule
c'est une éolienne test de l'école
centrale de nantes mode abrégeons
comment expliquer avec tous les
ingénieurs dont regorge la france qu'on
n'ait pas au moins un parc éolien
évidemment ce n'est peut-être pas tout
mais l'éolien ça fait partie des
énergies renouvelables sur lesquelles on
mise tout de même non
bien sûr alors pour revenir sur le
calcul je me suis dit je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec ce qu'a dit votre
phase moment porteur notamment parce que
ça vaut pas ce qu'on appelle le facteur
de charge et donc qu'on parlait de toute
façon la puissance d'une éolienne qui
est par définition intermittentes qui ne
produit pas tout le temps à la puissance
d'un réacteur nucléaire qui est
pilotable est donc produit à la demande
c'est de toute façon un calcul qui est
biaisé mais on va pas rendre les
intéressant parce qu'on peut quand même
en termes de mégawatts faire un
comparatif entre un débat de chiffres là
dessus pour une raison assez choqué en
france il ya une absence totale
d'éoliennes en mer
on va pas s'en sortir j'étais en train
de venir ne veux pas rentrer dans ce
débat de chiffres parce que je ma
conviction c'est qu'on a
fondamentalement besoin des deux et que
cette espèce de dualité dans laquelle et
europe ecologie les verts la france est
soumise et les républicains le
rassemblement national temps de nous
enfermer qui oppose l'énergie
renouvelable au nucléaire c'est le
climat hyper à coup sûr le gia claudie
on a besoin des deux rte le dis on a
besoin des deux fois les plus vite sur
le développement des énergies
renouvelables c'est une certitude et
effectivement il ya des process de
validation administrative
juridique ils sont aujourd'hui trop
lance la même chose pour le nucléaire
mais voilà je le redis encore une fois
notre ennemi commun salle doit bien les
émissions de gaz à effet serre soit si
on est réellement et sincèrement engagés
pour le climat en défense et le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
le président de la république a raison
on a tu de mener une politique du et en
même temps
parce que au fond je viens de le dire on
aura besoin des deux et si on veut
vraiment se battre sur le climat il va
falloir qu'on n'arrive à trouver
l'adéquation entre les deux et peut-être
à apaiser le débat public afin que celui
ci retrouve un peu de rationalité mode
brision mais pardonnez moi est ce que
c'est juste une question administrative
d'autorisation d'opposition ou est ce
que ce n'est pas une question de volonté
politique aussi ce choix des énergies
renouvelables puisque vous semblez le
souhaiter qu'il y en ait plus ah oui moi
je le souhaite et c'est pas c'est pas
qu'une question de volonté politique
qu'on regarde depuis le début du
quinquennat les énergies renouvelables
ont été largement déployée maintenant
quand vous voulez intégrer un parc
éolien
bientôt gérées avec la population
environnante il ya effectivement tout un
tas de processus et je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais qui prennent du
temps il faut qu'on arrive à les
raccourcis de la même chose quand vous
voulez implanter un parc d'éoliennes
d'éoliennes normal enfin vous voyez sur
suter vous voyez bien qu'il ya un
certain nombre de recours il faut
déminer l'ensemble de ces recours est
donc ça prend des années et a
effectivement à réfléchir sur comment
est ce qu'on arrive à aller plus
rapidement d'autant plus que le temps
presse parce que les centrales ne sont
pas des nucléaire qu'on a qui produisent
l'immense majorité la grande majorité de
nos lecteurs notre électricité pardon ne
sont pas éternels et donc il va bien
falloir pour renouvelle nos capacités de
production quoi qu'il arrive on va
devoir renouveler nos capacités de
production il faut que ce soit vers du
nucléaire et vers des énergies
renouvelables mais effectivement et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
président de la république a annoncé à
juste titre le renouvellement du parc
nucléaire français alors quel avenir de
ce texte à la commission européenne dont
on parlait au début de cette émission
qui s'apprête donc à classer je le
rappelle le gaz et le nucléaire comme
des énergies durables sous certaines
conditions aux marinas et dosable
maintenant être examiné par les parties
prenantes elles vont pouvoir proposer
des ajustements jusqu'au 12 janvier puis
le texte devrait être publiée par la
commission fin janvier et ensuite il y
aura un vote à la majorité qualifiée
donc ça va être compliqué de le rejeter
je vous fait réagir bien sûr michelle
rivasi puisqu'il faudrait donc une
puisqu'une majorité qualifiée d'états
suffit sur les 27 pour qu'ils passent
donc difficile dont justement de se
retrouver avec un nombre d'états
suffisant qui s'y opposent marina oui
tout à fait
il faut pas penser que parce qu'on a ce
texte aujourd'hui ça y est c'est adopter
le nucléaire et le gaz rentrer
officiellement dans les airs nine et
énergie verte européenne absolument pas
vous venez de le rappeler il ya encore
un certain nombre d'étapes en réalité il
faut que y ait un certain nombre de pays
qui s'opposent pour que ce texte soit
bloqué il va y avoir donc une véritable
bataille qui va être très serré et qui
va falloir suivre dans les semaines qui
arrivent méchaal rivasi vous pensez que
il pourrait y avoir un nombre de pays
suffisant qui fasse capoter ce texte de
la commission
alors il ya deux niveaux même je dirais
qu'il ya là trois les deux niveaux c'est
d'abord le conseil donc c'est les états
il faudrait avoir une majorité d'états
qui votent contre
cette taxonomie et ça va être très
difficile à obtenir vu ce que je vous ai
dit que notre président est allé
quémander à des pays très démocratique
de se tenir au stade sony on a cloud
nucléaire donc ça je n'y crois pas mais
reprenons il ya le parlement qui va
voter aussi à la majorité pour ou contre
cette action nommée il ya une troisième
action qu'une action juridique vous
savez que les autrichiens ont fait faire
une étude juridique
et ils ont constaté que la taxonomie
telle qu'elle est proposée par la
commission n'est pas valable et le
luxembourg vient de s'associer aux
autrichiens donc là la cour de justice
européenne va être saisie par ces deux
états pour non conformité en quelque
sorte de la taxonomie en fonction des
critères établis dans le règlement qui
fixe et les critères de
développement durable
donc je dirais vous voyez je l'avais de
l'histoire n'est pas finie et puis juste
je voudrais revenir en arrière pas trop
ça des raisons qu'on avançait lui reste
4 minutes et politiques pour développer
les énergies renouvelables en france la
preuve c'est que on n'est pas dans les
objectifs qu'elle s'est fixés l'europe
sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables en france en est en retard
sur ses objectifs
c'est pour ça que
vous voyez que maintenant comme ça passe
pas de dire on va développer que le
nucléaire on rajoute maintenant les
énergies renouvelables mais vous voyez
que c'est quand même scandaleux que on
n'est qu'une petite éoliennes de 2
mégawatts qui fonctionne en france quand
vous voyez que on a une cote incroyable
et que on a été incapable de mettre en
place des éoliennes offshore mode
brégeon la montre bien qu'il a jamais eu
de volonté politique mode région un mot
justement les ministres verts du nouveau
gouvernement allemand parce que eux ils
sont quand même assez tenace et plutôt
opposés justement à cette taxonomie est
ce qu'ils peuvent entraîner 19 autres
états européens où une majorité de
députés députés pour voter justement
contre ce texte de la commission
c'est moi je pense que le texte enfin
que le nucléaire restera inclus dans la
taxonomie européenne en tout cas je le
souhaite maintenant c'est évidemment les
discussions entre états mais voilà je
souhaite que ça puisse y rester est ce
que ça peut être une majeure question
une question majeure entre la france et
l'allemagne est-ce que olaf scholz et
emmanuel macron se parle tous les jours
de 7 ce problème finalement ce qu'ils
ont effectivement trouvé un deal
en tout cas c'est forcément une question
majeure à l'échelle européenne
question du climat sont là les réglera
pas indépendamment les uns des autres et
on est obligé d'avoir une action commune
il ya effectivement un pas qui a été
fait vers des allemands parce
qu'aujourd'hui des allemands parce
qu'ils font le choix de sortir du
nucléaire se tourner massivement vers le
gaz à mon avis c'est une erreur c'est
une erreur pour le climat c'est une
erreur pour leur souveraineté je
rappelle que 30% du gaz qui est utilisé
en europe provient de la russie à
l'heure où les prix explosent et où on
voit la tension sur le marché de
l'énergie sadoine je pense vraiment de
questionner je souhaite vraiment qu'on
puisse travailler main dans la main avec
avec les amants avec l'ensemble des pays
européens
chacun a des atouts différents les taux
d'ensoleillement sont pas les mêmes les
cotes disponibles pour l'installation
d'éoliennes offshore sont pas non plus
les mêmes les les éoliennes fonctionnent
pas de la même façon d'un pays à un
autre en fonction du vent où le son du
climat et donc c'est jeu c'est normal
que chacun puisse avoir choisir la
stratégie qui lui semblait le meilleur
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone en
tout état de cause je remarque à chaque
fois sortir du nucléaire c'est choisir
le gaz c'est revenir vers des énergies
fossiles il faut coordonner à l'échelle
européenne l'inclusion du nucléaire dans
la taxonomie est un grand pas en avant
parce que ça va nous permettre aux
français de continuer à le développer à
d'autres pays européens qui le
souhaitent de le faire également ça nous
permettra de notamment nous en vendre à
l'export merci beaucoup marina juste un
petit mot de conclusion est ce que la
coalition allemande pour exploser sur ce
sujet si finalement la france et
l'allemagne arrivent à se mettre
d'accord
écoutez c'est fort c'est fort peu
probable
très clairement les verts ont une place
de choix ils ont posé leurs conditions
et donc au maximum ces conditions et
bien on tentera en allemagne en tout cas
de les respecter c'est assez évident
après je vous le disais à tout à l'heure
loin de le lcl ne seront pas du tout
facile à réaliser ces conditions en
particulier celle du charbon c'est
évident de combat politique n'est pas
encore terminée en tout cas merci marine
à marbella finances notre spécialiste
environnement et qui présente une fois
deux fois par mois par dont les missions
élémentaires merci beaucoup mode région
d'avoir été avec nous porte parole la
république en marche ingénieur dans le
nucléaire également et puis merci à vous
michèle rivasi eurodéputée europe
ecologie les verts merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis reste avec nous sur
france 24
[Musique]